-We are hanging out
with the star of "Aquaman."
Jason Momoa right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The best.
In the movie, of course, Aquaman
is a master of the trident.
Where is he?
Okay, there you are.
Oh, my gosh. Dude.
Oh, my gosh. I'm telling you.
I swear to God, every second,
I feel like he might just snap
one of these days,
and I'm just --
That's how it ends for me.
A trident.
Tonight -- Whew!
I want to test out --
I don't know why.
I want to test out your trident
throwing skills in real life.
Are you ready for this?
-I'm ready, Jimmy.
-All right, let's check out
our target right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
Now, look. This is the ocean.
-Yeah!
That's Ocean Master,
the legendary arch rival
of Aquaman.
That's 15 points for his head,
10 for the body.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-Yes. Take it off.
-No, no.
-Take it off.
-It's not --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Whoo!
-All right. Here we go.
10 points for the body.
25 for under the --
Below the belt.
The jewels of the sea.
And if you hit Nemo or Dory,
that's negative 20 points.
We'll get three throws each.
I will go first.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Get ready for this.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You sick son of a bitch!
[ Applause ]
-[ Screams ]
[ Shouting ] Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
-Yeah!
-Oh, my God.
-You better knock
before you come into my house!
-All right. I'll knock
before I come to your house.
What does that mean?
Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
[ Glass shatters ]
I just heard broken glass.
I don't even know
how that's possible.
Holy moly.
Ooh!
♪♪
-[ Shouts ]
-That's right. Here we go.
-A tiebreaker. Here we go.
-I can do it. I can top it.
-You got it?
-Get ready for me, man.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
For the win! For the win!
You better knock --
Ring the doorbell
if you come to my house.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Grunts ]
-Ohh! The winner!
The one and only Jason Momoa!
[ Laughs ] Jason Momoa.
Check him out hosting "Saturday
Night Live" this weekend.
Go see "Aquaman."
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." Stick around.
♪♪